o voto em 1989
eu estudava na escola técnica federal da
bahia lá eu tinha muitos amigos e entre
eles a alguém muito especial com quem
conversava muito
ele era um cara muito legal só que vira
e mexe quando estava lá conversando com
ele ele simplesmente virava a cara por
outro lado para falar com outra pessoa e
isso aconteceu várias vezes em várias
conversas nossas até que teve um dia eu
me lembro como se fosse hoje eu estava
lá falando com ele animadamente de
repente ele virou a cara pra falar com
outra pessoa a mais nesse dia eu fui lá
bate no ombro dele e falei marcos
eu estou aqui falando com você e você
vira a cara pra falar com outra pessoa
ao que ele me olhou nos olhos e disse
pronta e secamente seja interessante
seja interessante 17 anos cheio de
hormônios incerteza de conflitos
próprios da idade e eu recebi essa bomba
em forma de frase seja interessante
naquele momento um fato marcante
aconteceu em minha vida e um mix de
emoções veio à tona frustração tristeza
raiva eu fiquei me sentindo excluído eu
queria voar no pescoço dele mas na minha
mente só passava uma coisa você vai ver
se eu não vou me tornar interessante
você vai ver
então eu comecei a ler muito e estudar
muito me informar de tudo o que
acontecia naquela época eu estava me
tornando altamente competitivo
eu queria simplesmente me tornar melhor
que importava segundo terceiro eu queria
era ser primeiro e aquilo estava dando
resultado até porque eu comecei a
escutar coisas como como ele é
inteligente como ele é inteligente e
aquilo era uma delícia
pra mim e para o meu ego sim eu não
sabia mas eu estava alimentando em lobo
orais chamado ego e ele estava crescendo
eu me tornei um a um
rapaz inteligente é verdade até porque
eu comecei a ficar um tanto quanto
vaidoso e arrogante naquela linha sim
mas eu usava régua de comparação o tempo
todo eu só queria ser melhor que outras
pessoas olhando pra trás e vendo essa
época da minha vida eu cheguei à
conclusão que você ter conhecimento sem
ter consciência é como você ter uma
mente sem alma
eu estava no caminho certo afinal ter
conhecimento é algo fascinante mas pelos
motivos errados
eu estava lá para ser melhor que no
entanto aqueles caminhos do conhecimento
me levaram a deparar com as trilhas da
consciência e da espiritualidade e isso
mudou tudo
o tempo passou e eu então enviei um
e-mail com um projeto que eu tinha
desenvolvido pra um amigo e recebi como
resposta que a equipa de great work
continue esse belo trabalho nossa aquilo
foi outro fato marcante que aconteceu em
minha vida afinal de contas esse novo
sentimento que estava surgindo era de
felicidade
eu fiquei muito feliz eu queria contar
ao mundo que o mesmo marcos que 89
mandava eu ser interessante agora é
elogiável meu trabalho e então na minha
mente só passava uma coisa o ao eu estou
me tornando uma pessoa interessante e
foi a partir daquele meio daquela
conexão que eu tive um insight todas as
vezes que eu me conectar com alguém eu
possa sair dessa conexão uma pessoa
melhor e foi o que eu fiz a partir dali
toda e qualquer pessoa com quem eu me
conectava eu saía desse encontro uma
pessoa melhor
maravilhoso não é mesmo exceto por um
pequeno detalhe me tornar me levava de
volta aos tempos do como ele é
inteligente e me mandava de volta para
os braços do ego
só que agora estava atento pois as
trilhas da consciência da
espiritualidade me levaram a conhecer um
novo caminho o caminho do
autoconhecimento e então eu rezo
significa aquele insight
eu pensei todas as vezes que eu me
conectar com outra pessoa eu posso dar o
meu melhor para que o outro saia daquele
encontro também uma pessoa melhor e foi
aí que eu percebi que conhecimento com
consciência gera um transbordamento de
propósito
o meu foco não era mais em mim mas no
outro e consequentemente quanto mais
focado no outro mas nós aprendíamos mas
então eu me perguntei qual foi o ponto
de inflexão um ponto de mudança que me
fez mudar o foco de mim para o outro
para o nos a elevação da minha
consciência infernal nem fez ao escutar
me fez acessar e escutar a minha melhor
versão
e foi então que eu percebi que a escuta
era uma ponte para o aprendizado e nessa
época eu tive contato pela primeira vez
com os vídeos com os textos do mestre
ruben alves que dizia mais ou menos
assim eu vejo anunciado vários cursos de
oratória
não vejo anunciado cursos de escutar a
história porque as pessoas estão
querendo aprender a falar não aprender a
ouvir e o texto dizia mais nossa
incapacidade de ouvir é a manifestação
mais constante e sutil da nossa
arrogância e vaidade e foi então que eu
percebi eu percebi que toda a minha
arrogância e vaidade vinha justamente da
minha não escuta
então eu pensei por que não criar um
curso de escutar tório e eu fui além
criar não só um curso mas o estilo de
vida e comecei a pesquisar e prattica
escutatória com deus colts com meus
amigos e minha família no meu trabalho
em todos os lugares e naquela época eu
cheguei a esse conceito de que a
conscientização da escuta nos leva a um
aprendizado potencial a um estágio de
aprendizado potencial e naquela época e
hoje essa frase me inquietava se todos
estão falando quem está escutando quem
tá escutando porque num diálogo quando o
outro fala e
ouvir a voz dele é escuta mas se o outro
faz você está escutando a sua própria
voz na sua mente isso ego
porque eu não consigo falar uma frase em
russo porque eu não sei russo significa
que tudo aquilo que a gente fala é
aquilo que a gente já sabe se a gente só
fala aquilo que a gente já sabe quando é
que a gente aprende quando a gente
escuta quando a gente escuta
no entanto as pessoas estão tão cheias
disse que elas defendem os seus pontos
de vista num diálogo como se fosse uma
verdade absoluta e elas entram para uma
conversa de xícara cheia não escutam e
por isso é um aprendizado e ela sai do
jeito que elas entraram ao invés disso a
gente entrar para uma conversa um
diálogo com a xícara vazia a gente então
vai expor o nosso ponto de vista como
sendo pura e simplesmente à vista de um
ponto
então outro poderá se servir na
quantidade o que ele quiser
daquilo que está sendo dito e haverá
escuta haverá aprendizado e sairemos
desse encontro melhores do que entramos
e como é que então a gente pode entrar
em estágio de aprendizado o potencial de
maneira leve gradual e apaixonada
são cinco etapas ea gente começa pelo
ouvir direcionando nossa capacidade
auditiva na direção de quem fala para
então começar a escutar escutar com
presença escutar com a empatia escutar
com a consciência que está ali na frente
do outro é uma oportunidade imensa de
transformação para ambos e quando você
está nesse estado você expande a sua
consciência de tal forma que você começa
a escutar
além da audição a escutar
além da visão a escutar além de todos os
sentidos e é impressionante o número de
pontos que as nossas almas se tocam
nesse estado
em todos esses anos pesquisando e
praticando escutatória eu cheguei a 3
por isso que são essenciais para que a
gente chega e escuta plena
a primeira deles é o estado de presença
é estar no aqui e agora
no ano passado associando coisas aquilo
que está sendo dito ou já elaborando que
você vai dizer enquanto o outro está
dizendo estar de presença é você honrar
o tempo do outro e o seu tempo
o segundo fator é o não julgamento não
julgar você entender que tudo aquilo que
o outro diz faz parte da história dele
faz todo o sentido para ele o não
julgamento você está com a xícara vazia
e acolher aquilo que está sendo dito
o terceiro ponto é a intenção positiva
quando a gente está em estado de atenção
positivo a gente deixa aflorar deixa
emergir a nossa melhor versão
e essa nossa melhor versão se conecta
com a melhor versão do outro e então o
aprendizado é fantástico para ambos
além disso tem duas dicas que eu preciso
compartilhar com vocês porque fez toda a
diferença na minha vida
no meu caminhar até aqui a primeira
delas é que independente do estado do
outro estado de espírito menos elevado
do do estado de um morro das palavras
mais femininas que estejam sendo
proferidas lembrem disso não é pessoal
se alguém te oferece algo que você
aceita aquilo passa a ser seu
mas se alguém oferecesse ao e você
recusa isso continua sendo do outro
por isso só colha aquilo que é dificl
ante o resto não é pessoal ea segunda
dica é que toda pessoa de qualquer
pessoa tem uma história fascinante de
vida e tem muito a nos ensinar
por isso têm interesse genuíno outro tem
interesse genuíno naquilo que está sendo
dito e os benefícios que escutar tora
pode nos trazer
primeiro quando você está em estado de
aprendizado potencial você ouve o melhor
do outro e você começa a aprender em
nível e exponencial
sem contar nos aumento dos resultados
positivos na sua vida pessoal e
profissional
em todos esses anos aprendendo e
compartilhando eu poderia contar
inúmeros cases pra vocês
como case de mães que melhorar o seu
relacionamento com seus filhos autistas
com estudantes que melhoraram seu
desempenho na escola e na faculdade de
profissionais que ascenderam em suas
empresas e até de familiares que
relataram seus laços
mas eu vou me ater a um pequeno grande
caso de uma pessoa formada que procura
um estágio lá na minha empresa
passei para o primeiro programador e ele
foi recusado não esse cara não aprende
passei para o segundo também foi
recusado
mas eu vi a intenção positiva nos olhos
dele e fizemos um coaching escutatória
hoje dois anos depois ele é líder de
tecnologia lá da empresa e um dos
melhores programadores que eu conheço a
escutar histórias traz esse tipo de
benefício para vida da gente traz mais
notório nos torna as pessoas mais
simpáticas e também transborda
felicidade na nossa vida e na vida de
todas as pessoas que se conectam conosco
para fechar aquela gestalt vocês lembram
do marcos e 89 de 2011 pois é
hoje é meu sócio numa empresa de
tecnologia ea gente desenvolve inúmeros
aplicativos mas entre eles aplicativo de
escuta porque escutatória faz parte do
nosso dna
aplicativos como o viva voz em que a
gente escuta denúncias de violência
contra a mulher também aplicativos como
o diário de bordo um aplicativo de
desenvolvimento humano em que a pessoa
pode se ao escutar e aprender consigo e
também um aplicativo como solidária da
pe em que a gente escuta as pessoas que
querem ajudar e escutamos as entidades
que precisam de ajuda e conectamos esses
pontos
compartilhar e vivenciar a escutar a
história é o meu propósito
por isso eu vim aqui expor com uma
conscientização da escuta nos levam a um
estado de aprendizado potencial
hoje na minha vida seria interessante já
não faz mais o menor sentido o que eu
repito como um mantra na minha mente e
no meu coração é seja em
pensado seja interessado
aproveite cada oportunidade de conexão e
faça a diferença na vida de cada pessoa
que se conectar com vocês e vocês vão
ver a diferença que isso vai fazer na
vida de ambos
para finalizar eu gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês um trecho de um
texto do mestre ruben alves aqui eu
dedico esse tex o que as pessoas mais
desejam é alguém que quer discutir de
maneira calma e tranquila em silêncio
sem dar conselhos sem que digam se eu
fosse você
a gente ama não é a pessoa que fala
bonito mas a pessoa que escuta bonito
a fala só é bonita com ela nasce de uma
longa e silenciosa escuta é na escuta
que o amor nasce e ela não escuta que
ele termina não aprende nos livros
aprendi prestando atenção muito obrigado
[Aplausos]